MALE SPEAKER: Hello
and welcome everyone.
We have a very special
guest with us here today,
Hewitt Heiserman.
He authored the book,
"It's Earnings That Count,"
and he is currently finishing
his second book, "The Checklist
Investor."
The interesting thing
about today's talk
is that he is
going to be sharing
material which I am told
might become his third book.
So you guys are the first
ones to get a look at it.
Mr. Heiserman is a member of the
Boston Security Analyst Society
and CFA Institute.
He's been quoted in various
publications including the Wall
Street Journal and Barron's.
He has spoken to several
CFA groups as well as
Fidelity Management,
Franklin Templeton,
and the American Association
of Individual Investors.
He is, interestingly,
an Ironman finisher
and is active in open
land preservation.
Lastly, and I guess
more importantly,
he is a recipient of the
Kenyan College's faculty award
for distinguished achievement.
And he will be speaking to
us wearing his teacher's hat.
We are really glad
to have you here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please join me
in welcoming, Hewitt Heiserman.
[APPLAUSE]
HEWITT HEISERMAN:
The title of my talk
is Ben Graham and
the Growth Investor.
And if you know
anything about Ben,
you know that famously
he was a value investor.
He wanted to buy companies
that were cheap in relation
to their corporate net worth.
And this may seem
like a paradox,
but I will explain
everything shortly.
I want to draw your
attention to a study that
was done by Jeff Smart,
a PhD, a venture capital.
And these VC firms, including
some here in this area
were profiled by their
personality type.
And then their
performance in terms
of which companies
they were investing in.
Again, these are early
stage pre-revenue companies,
highly speculative,
maybe just a couple
of people, no
assets to speak of.
The personality type
that performed the best
were the airline captains.
They averaged almost an 80%
IRR on their investments.
The airline captain followed
a discipline repeatable
and explainable
process when they
were interviewing potential
candidates to finance.
In other words they were
using a checklist approach.
And this applies to what I'm
going to talk about today.
This chart here shows that for
the last 30 years, just 25%
of the stocks created all
the stock market returns.
And 75% of the stocks either
broke even or they lost money.
And this chart shows that one
out of five is a big winner.
40% lost money and one out
of five is a big loser.
So if we can tilt the odds
of success in our favor,
that's a tremendous advantage.
So we're going to be using
a checklist approach, which
is kind of like a race, where
there's a series of hurdles.
And in our approach,
not every company
will reach the finish line.
You probably know that
airline pilots use checklists.
And even a company called
Google uses checklists.
There's a great book by Atul
Gawande called, "The Checklist
Manifesto."
If you haven't read
it, there's a lot
of good information in there.
So here's our checklist
for the growth investor.
We're going to go
through these five items.
We're going to spend
a little more time
on number one, earnings
quality and number five, sell.
The three in the
middle, we're going
to go over a little bit faster.
I want to acknowledge the
luminaries that have spoken
here in this series before me.
I've tried to watch
every presentation.
I've taken notes as I've
watched these other individual
speakers-- a lot of
excellent content.
I want to acknowledge the people
that have helped me get here.
My high school, the Haverford
School-- I refer to last year.
It had the number one
ranked boys lacrosse team
in the United States.
Kenyon College has
more NCAA championships
than any school in
the United States,
with the exception of
three California schools--
USC, UCLA, and Stanford.
Kenyon was named as having one
of the most beautiful campuses
in the world
according to Forbes.
And Chuck Huggins, who
was the CEO of See's Candy
was a graduate.
Charlie Monger, who is the vice
chairman at Berkshire Hathaway
said that
See's was their first
high quality company
that Berkshire bought
and that opened up
the door to Coca-Cola.
They were able to realize
the value of pricing
power, competitive
advantage, and some
of these qualitative
things that they really
hadn't paid attention to
earlier in their partnership.
And of course I
want to acknowledge
John Bogle, the founder and
former CEO of the Vanguard
Group.
Mr. Bogle wrote the
forward to my book.
If he were here today
he'd say three things.
Number one, no
one knows nothing.
That was the advice
he first learned
when he got in the
business in the early 50s.
Second, most of us
should have most
of our money in index funds.
And third, his life's
motto, press on regardless.
When I visited Mr. Bogle
last April at the Vanguard
headquarters, interestingly
enough, Google's historian
was on their campus that day.
And he had just left Mr. Bogle's
office as I was going in.
After my book was published,
Barron's wrote this article
that I wrote about the
earnings power chart
which we're going to discuss.
They also published a letter
to the editor that I wrote,
in which I said-- this
is in December 2004.
You had just gone public
in August of that year.
I said that it was
unlikely that Google
would make $14 billion
dollars of earnings by 2014.
Actually I said $10 billion.
In fact you made $14.4 billion.
So congratulations.
I also mention this because
five years ago I bought
a company that went bankrupt.
That was the first
time I'd ever bought
a company that went bankrupt.
The point is that these are
my ideas, but it's your money.
So I want you to test
everything that I say today.
I'm finishing a book called,
"The Checklist Manifesto,"
which Miles Thompson at Columbia
University Press will publish.
That should be
available in a year.
Just to help you get the
lay of the land here,
there are six broad reasons
why you might buy a company's
stock-- yield, growth, the
company's cheap in relation
to its net assets, people,
a special situation
like a spin-off, and then
other includes short-selling.
I'm going to address this second
column from the left, growth
investing.
I think this is
the most intuitive
of the six approaches
or the most human.
We plant a tree in our yard
and we watch the tree grow
and then it has
flowers or fruit.
Or if we're a
parent we have kids
and we watch our kids grow up.
I think we can all relate
to the growth approach.
One of the great growth
stocks of the last 25 years
is Microsoft.
If you or your parents were
lucky or prescient enough
to buy $10,000 in
1990, those shares
grew to a million dollars
by the end of 1999.
Now you can see in
these blue bars here--
that's earnings per share.
And you can see how they
keep growing over time.
And that's what
Wall Street loves.
There are some advantages
on a growth company--
the chance to make a lot
of money, which gives you
more control over your life.
You may even be able to go
on and do something else,
help other people.
There's no exquisite
timing required.
You can buy a [INAUDIBLE]
position today and then build
that position as you get
to know the company better.
There's no capital gains tax
so your money compounds faster.
And then there is the
psychological benefit--
the pride of discovery, the joy
of ownership, sort of thing.
But it's important to point out
that growth investing is very
difficult. Now it's not as
difficult as free climbing
at Yosemite or even
getting a job here.
Just to introduce the
price earnings ratio,
Amazon's price is about $507.
It's going to earn
about $4.46 this year.
So its price to
earnings ratio is 114.
If Amazon makes that same
level of earnings forever,
you'll wait 114 years to get
your stock price purchase back.
Alphabet's about
20 times earnings.
The market's about 21 times
earnings and then Apple
about 10 times earnings.
I introduce the P/E
ratio because this chart
shows that on the left these
are your growth companies.
These are the companies
that had the highest
price earnings ratio.
And the companies
that we believe
are going to have the most
growth in front of them,
we tend to bid up their price.
So they have the lowest
subsequent investment returns.
And then the companies
over on the right, these
are your lowest P/E stocks.
And the irony is that they
had the highest returns.
There are three
reasons-- three obstacles
that confront the
growth investor.
First of all we buy a company
that has poor earnings quality.
Second, we buy a company just
as a its competitive advantage
wanes.
And third, we overpay for
value that never materializes.
So here's our checklist that
we're going to work with today.
And we're going to start with
number one, earnings quality.
And to do this I want
to introduce generally
accepted accounting
principals, or GAAP.
GAAP is Robert's Rules
of Order for America.
When you open up an
annual report or a 10-K
and you look at the
financial statements,
that's GAAP accounting.
And we need GAAP accounting
just like motorists
need traffic lights.
If we didn't have
them we'd have chaos.
But net income and
earnings per share, we
think of them as hard
numbers or fixed numbers.
But that's not the case
as I learned 30 years ago
when I read this landmark
book, "Quality of Earnings,"
by Thornton O'Glove.
He points out in this book
that there are many accounting
decisions that a CFO can make
that influence just how much
or how little money
a company makes.
Bill Ackman, a billionaire
hedge fund manager
describes, "Quality of
Earnings" on his short list
of recommended reading.
Just as an aside, after
I finished my first book
and I was looking for people
to write an endorsement,
the first person I
called was Mr. O'Glove.
I didn't know him.
And we talked and
he quickly said yes.
And then I found that
after that conversation,
as I was asking for other
endorsements for my book,
when I told them that I got the
green light from Mr. O'Glove,
the endorsements came
fast and furious.
He wrote just a--
just as a side note,
he wrote an op-ed piece
for Barron's last fall.
And he argues that
Berkshire Hathaway
should-- it's time for
Berkshire to deconglomerate.
It's too big and that the pieces
are worth more than the sum.
So this will be an
interesting trend.
It's a non-consensus view.
This will be something to watch
over the next several years.
Anyway, other books
that I've read which
influenced by
thinking, the first,
"Cash Flow and
Security Analysis"
by Joshua Livnat and Ken Hackel.
And they introduce what's
called a free cash flow income
statement.
And their argument is that the
GAAP income statement which
we see here in the center,
it doesn't tell you
how much cash is coming
in and out of a company.
And so a better
measure is one that
takes into account investment
in fixed and working capital.
So let's look at that
Alphabet's results for 2015.
These results were
just posted on Friday.
I pulled them off
of your website.
You made almost $75 billion.
So I'm in the GAAP
column right now.
You made $75 billion of revenue.
You had $59 billion of expenses.
Your net income
is $16.4 billion.
And earnings per share
almost $22 a share.
On a free cash flow basis, we're
going to expense investment
in fixed capital.
Well, what does that mean?
That means if you're going
out and you're buying rockets,
for example or other businesses,
or other machinery or equipment
that is above your depreciation,
that is a use of cash.
And depreciation is just your
old capital spending that
gets written off over time.
So in Alphabet's
case last year you
made an investment of
$8.5 billion dollars.
So that's a $8.5 billion
of cash that's coming out
of your corporate
checking account
that does not appear in
the GAAP income statement.
Another-- yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HEWITT HEISERMAN: It's
above depreciation.
That's an excellent question.
Yes.
What you do basically is
you take capital spending,
you go to the
statement of cash flow
and take capital spending
plus acquisitions
minus depreciation.
And the reason I
include acquisitions
because many companies
buy other companies
because that's a faster
way of getting up
to speed than building
something de novo, where
you got to hire people,
you got to get--
so it's just a faster way.
So $8.6 billion invested
in-- $8.5 billion
invested in fixed capital.
Working capital investment
is more modest, $827 million.
You have some receivables.
You don't have any inventory.
So in the big scheme of things,
that's just a rounding error.
So on a cash basis, if you
will, Alphabet last year
made $5.96 billion.
And one thing I like to
look at is I like to see,
what's the percentage
of free cash flow
earnings to GAAP earnings.
And here we see
that ratio is 37%.
So that idea is from
this book, "Cash Flow
and Security Analysis."
I then read another book
called, "The Quest for Value,"
after reading about Coca-Cole.
There was a cover story in
Fortune magazine, 1995, 1996,
and Roberto Goizueta who was
the CEO was lauding this EVA
approach to capital allocation.
And Coke at that time had
a 10-year track record
of creating some serious
amounts of stockholder wealth.
This EVA income statement is
unique for its own two reasons.
Now you'll notice that it
does not expense investment
in working capital, at
least not immediately.
What it does expense directly
is intangibles like R&D, money
that you spend on patents.
These would be relevant
for your business.
Other businesses,
it might be the cost
of buying subscription
lists or marketing efforts,
pre-store opening costs.
So I want you to compare the
difference between the GAAP
expense for intangibles
and the EVA approach.
There's about a $4
billion difference.
The EVA approach
actually credits
you back about $4 billion
worth of expenses.
Because the mindset
here is, we're
going to spread
those intangibles
over their expected useful life.
So if you're investing in
your people, your processes,
or your intellectual
property today,
we don't expect you to derive
value from those outlays today.
We think they'll occur in year
two, three, four, five, six.
So we're going to try
to match current sales
with current expenses and future
sales with future expenses.
The other income statement
here that's noteworthy
is the interest expense
or cost of capital
which is about $5.7 billion.
In the EVA approach, not only
is debt treated as an expense
but so is stockholder's equity,
which you have a lot of.
So in the EVA approach, if you
buy Alphabet stock or you buy
Coca-Cola stock--
Procter & Gamble stock,
you have an expected
return mindset.
You expect to get some
return on your stock.
And so what the EVA
approach tries to do
is to capture that cost.
Now if accounting's
not your thing,
the good news is, that's the
end of the accounting for today.
So I was in a quandary.
When do I use the free
cash flow income statement
and when do I use the
EVA income statement?
And I built both of
these alternate income
statements in Excel on my
computer, and I had them
and I just didn't
know which way to go.
And then I read a passage from
one of Ben Graham's books.
Now Ben is the
first great investor
teacher of the modern age.
He came to the United States
with his family, graduated
from Columbia with
three offers to teach
at three different departments.
His father just passed away.
He needed to make some money for
his mother and two younger sons
so he got a job on Wall Street.
And he started making a
lot of money pretty quick.
And then the depression came
along and he was speculating
and Ben got wiped out.
So he re-jigged his
investment methodology
and he developed this margin
of safety principle, which
you're probably familiar with.
And we all use margin
of safety in our lives.
If you have to be at work
at-- what time do you
have to be at work here?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Whenever.
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Whenever.
All right, if you have
to be here at whenever,
and you know it
takes a half hour,
you leave 45 minutes before,
just in case something happens.
So that was his framework for
approaching stock selection.
Warren Buffett explains
margin of safety this way.
He says, "you build a bridge
that can carry a 30,000 pound
truck but then you have a
weight limit of 10,000 pounds."
Now, Alphabet has
a margin of safety.
It's a redundancy.
It is your data centers that
you have around the world.
And I assume you have them.
You had them as of last week.
Right?
So it's the same idea.
It's a margin of safety.
If one data center
goes down, you've
got others that you can use.
Anyway, Ben writes in the,
"Intelligent Investor,"
he says there are two types--
the defensive investor who
wants to avoid committing
[INAUDIBLE] mistakes,
and the enterprising
investor who
wants to own companies that
are more promising than most.
So I'm thinking about this.
I'm thinking, huh,
the defensive investor
is kind of like a
commercial banker.
If it's raining, they want the
umbrella that they lent you.
They want it back.
And they think about
corporate profitability kind
of like a lemonade stand.
Because the way that
they're going to make
money is if you can
repay that loan.
And so they're going to focus
on how much cash you generate.
Their not going to get
rich owning your business.
So their mindset is very
pessimistic, hard money.
And that's the way the free cash
flow income statement works.
And then the other
personality type,
I think of it as like the
way a venture capitalist
looks at a business.
Here at Alphabet, you have
two funding entities, right?
They're both early stage.
This is according to what
I read in the papers.
When they sit down and they
look at business opportunities,
they're creating a pro forma.
So they're modeling out
revenue going out several years
and then they're
modeling out expenses.
They're going to
depreciate or spread
over time intangibles
and capital spending.
But also they want
to make a return.
Because your stockholders
want to make a return.
So they're going to have a
line in there for the financing
that they're providing
to this entity.
So I want to make a proposal
that the GAAP income
statement is too,
"venture capitalist"
for the defensive
investor and is too,
"commercial banker" for
the enterprising investor.
And now we're going
to return to Alphabet
and we're going to
look at five years
worth of your performance.
Now the blue bar, that's
your GAAP net income.
And that's in the
middle because it's
kind of in between these two
opposing viewpoints about what
is corporate profitability.
We see a progression of
increased positive progression
over the last five years.
So that's impressive.
We have our defensive
profits on the left.
And you see that
beginning in 2013,
the gap between GAAP
net income has widened.
And that's because you're making
tremendous investments in fixed
capital.
Now if you had a
lot of debt, if you
had a history of write-offs,
if your ownership culture--
if I wasn't comfortable
with your ownership culture,
if I looked at
this dichotomy, it
would make me somewhat troubled.
In Alphabet's case,
there's nothing
to suggest that these
investments in the future
are anything to worry about.
With the enterprise
income statement,
we can see that
there's a tighter
correlation between GAAP
profits and enterprise profits.
So this gives me
comfort that you're
making pretty high
returns on your earnings.
Most of what I'm
talking about today,
these are ideas that
I've collated and thought
about from other investors.
I guess my one little
contribution to this field,
such as it is, is what I call
the earnings power chart.
And so in this
approach, we are going
to reject the GAAP
income statement,
because it's like
being half pregnant.
We're going to focus on the
relationship between defense
and enterprise in profits.
And as you would think, the
best-- there are four boxes.
And the best box to be is
in the upper right box.
That means you have defensive
profits and enterprise profits.
And that's where Alphabet
has resided for the last five
years.
We're now going to
step back 15 years
to a company called Enron.
Enron, in the late 1990s was one
of the best performing stocks.
It was a stock to last a decade.
This is of the 2000s, according
to a business publication
that's prominent.
Its CFO Andy Fastow
was named best
CFO, chief financial officer.
And a lot of people
were buying Enron
because they thought it
was a growth company.
Their thesis was based
on the income statement.
But when we look at
their earnings quality
through these two
alternate metrics,
we see that they were in the
lower left box every year.
So if you were thinking
of buying Enron
and you ran those numbers
through this model,
you'd have to
reject that thesis.
There might have been other
reasons to buy the company,
but it wasn't because of their
quality of their earnings
growth.
After I finished
looking at Enron,
I wondered, did either of these
two alternate income statements
or maybe the earning pie
chart tell you in advance
that something was wrong with
all these other companies?
All these other
companies here, they all
ran into financial difficulty
and cost stockholders lots
of money.
And so I wanted to
be like a-- I wanted
to see if there is
something you could
have known before the carnage.
And what I found is that often
the defensive income statement
told you that the company
had poor earnings quality
and you should go on high alert.
And often it was the
enterprising income statement.
And then sometimes it was both
alternate income statements
as we see with Enron.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HEWITT HEISERMAN: I didn't do
an academic study for that.
But what I did do
is, I just-- I would
say about probably 80%,
85% of the companies
that I looked at that ran
into financial difficulty, one
or both of these alternate
income statements
told you something was wrong.
And you made a case with
some of these companies that
go bankrupt-- you may not
expect that they go bankrupt,
but it gives you
a starting point
to say, OK, what's the
relationship between capital
spending and depreciation.
Or if working capital
is a problem, why
are their receivables going up?
Or why is their
inventory going up?
If their inventory is going
up, maybe consumer preferences
have changed, and
maybe consumers
are moving on to generation
five and they no longer
want generation
four which is all
that company may have to offer.
So it's really a starting point
for further investigation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HEWITT HEISERMAN: That's
a very good ratio to use,
and that's faster than
building an earnings power
chart, because that
information is available,
I think at Old School
Value, for example,
which is an excellent website
if you're a do it yourself
investor.
To answer your
question, I did not
look at these companies in
terms of their Altman score
because I was trying to learn--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Right.
Although the Z-score
may have picked up--
there's another ratio,
the accrual ratio.
And the accrual ratio may have
picked up similar problems.
But the reason why I like seeing
the three income statements
side by side, because you can
just go through each expense,
and you look for something
that's out of the ordinary.
And then you can take
that information,
you can take like
their investment rate
in fixed capital and
you can compare it
to the industry average.
So it's really like
a jumping off point
for to do further research if
you see something that's wrong.
OK.
Enough of failure.
Let's look at success.
Here is Microsoft
during the 1990s.
Remember, this company
turned a hypothetical $10,000
into a million dollars.
This is what we call--
to use Peter Lynch's
description, a 100 bagger.
What we see here--
I see three things.
Number one, the company
is in the upper right box,
so it has high quality earnings.
Number two, it's moving
every year in an upper right
direction.
So I call this an
earnings power staircase.
This is a sign of
profitable growth.
Not only is the company getting
bigger but it's getting better.
And then third, a
couple of these years,
look at the rate of change
from one year-- look at '97
to '98 and then '98 to '99.
It's just explosive growth.
And this is what
Wall Street loves.
There is a great book Chris
Mayer called, "100 Baggers."
If you want to learn more
about these kinds of companies
I highly recommend this book.
It came out last fall.
We're now going to look at other
companies that had earnings
power staircase-like patterns.
And we're just going to go
through this kind of fast.
But I just want
you to appreciate
that positive trajectory
in high quality earnings.
[INAUDIBLE] turned
$10,000 into $44,000.
First Cash Financial,
$10,000 into $86,000.
Apollo Group, $10
grand into $78,000.
Dell Computer, $10
grand into $1.3 million.
Cisco Systems, $10
grand into $631,000.
Paychex, $10,000 into $257,000.
Quality systems,
$10,000 into of $70,000.
Hansen Natural, $10,000
into $2.6 million.
Chico's FAS $10,000
into $73,000.
Monster Beverage,
$10,000 into $61,000.
Monster's interesting
because this
is the best performing
stock of the last 20 years.
A hypothetical $10000
investment grew to $10 million.
We're going to turn this
presentation into a book,
and I'll have much more to
say about Monster in the book.
So if your thesis is growth,
if you're a growth investor,
I want you to focus on companies
that are in the upper right box
and that are moving in an upward
right direction every year,
forging what I call an
earnings power staircase.
These are the companies
that have profitable growth.
And the next step is,
in our checklist here
is competitive advantage.
If a company is
forging a staircase,
it probably has a
competitive advantage.
There are five types.
If you saw Pat
Dorsey's presentation
here about a year
ago-- Pat is the expert
on competitive advantage.
When he was with Morning
Star he and his staff teased
out four competitive
advantages--
low cost, provider
high switching costs,
intangibles like brands and
patents and that sort of thing,
and then network effect,
the telephone, Facebook,
that sort of thing.
And then I add to
that list, ecosystems.
So if you make a
gadget, and the gadget
can talk to another
gadget that's
made by the same
company, then you
can transfer all that data go
as new versions of the gadget
come out.
That to me is an ecosystem.
With a network effect,
the more people
you have, the more
valuable the network.
But in theory, in an
ecosystem, you really
only need one customer.
Warren Buffet describes
a competitive advantage
as a moat.
And I bet that Larry
and Sergey and Eric
probably spend most of their
time thinking about this issue.
The castle is
Alphabet, and the moat
is whatever you guys,
men and women can come up
with that prevents the
competition from taking
your business.
Warren Buffett
says that if there
are alligators in the
moat, that's even better.
We're not going to talk
about competitive advantage
except to say that if you
determine that a company has
a competitive advantage,
and it probably
does if it's
forging a staircase,
then you want to think
about the drivers that
affect intrinsic value.
Companies that have a
competitive advantage,
they're more valuable
than companies that don't
have a competitive advantage.
If you sell a
commodity, you really
don't have any pricing power.
People will go buy your
product from someone else
if they can get a better deal.
Intrinsic value
is our third step.
That's what the fair
worth of the business is.
Morningstar-- they do
a lot of great work
with estimating companies
intrinsic value.
They project that the business--
Alphabet's worth $755 a share.
The stock price as of
last week was $682.
So the price to
intrinsic value is 90%.
If you buy Alphabet stock
today, you're paying $0.90 cents
for a dollar's worth of value.
If you knew that,
for whatever reason,
the price intrinsic value
was going to go down to 75%,
then you would wait
because then you'd
get even more value
for your money.
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
spoke to your group.
And if you want to learn
more about valuation,
check out his presentation
which is excellent.
It's getting harder to estimate
a company's intrinsic value
because if you have
to make assumptions
about how long the
business is going to last.
And as this research shows,
in five years from today,
32% of US public companies
will be out of business.
They'll be either acquired
by other companies
or they'll just go bankrupt.
Versus 50 years
ago, it was only 5%.
So the rate of change
is accelerating,
and for better or
for worse, Alphabet
is one of the prime disruptors.
One item I want to point out
that is something to watch
is that your incremental
capital is trending down.
You're making bets that are
outside your core business.
Hopefully those bets
will pay off and then
that trend will reverse.
This will be something to watch.
To learn more about
intrinsic value
there's a great resource,
Valuentum Securities
which I subscribe to
and I highly recommend.
And I mentioned earlier,
Old School Value
which I also subscribe to.
They give you 10 years worth
of financial statements.
Just type in the symbol and
the information's right there
and they have a lot of
pre-programmed valuation
models.
So you don't have to build
the thing from scratch
and spend a couple
of weeks doing that.
All the information's
right at your fingertips.
Now I mentioned that
Ben Graham-- yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, he will be.
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Yep.
I've mentioned that Ben was
affected by the depression.
And so he took a hard money
approach to buying stocks.
So his method was
what he called--
this is after he figured
out a new approach.
He would buy companies
that were selling at 2/3
of their net working capital.
So taking your balance sheet
from December 31, 2015.
He gave 100% for your cash.
He'd give you a 75%
for your receivables.
You don't have any inventory.
And then he'd subtract
all your liabilities.
And then he'd take your
net working capital,
he'd multiply that
by 66% of that.
And then that would
leave you $36 billion.
He would pay $36 billion
for the business.
You've got 745 million shares
outstanding, so he'd paid $45.
Is that right? $48 for Google.
All right.
That's what he would buy it for.
Now we're at step
four, position sizing.
Position sizing is
simply, what percentage
of your portfolio
or your capital
are you going to put
into any single position?
Now it stands to reason
that if you have an edge,
then you should exploit it.
And this is what Warren Buffett
did after the famous salad oil
scandal in 1963.
It knocked shares of
American Express down.
Mr. Buffet determined that
American Express' franchise was
intact, and he put 40%
of the partnerships funds
into American Express and
it then went up five-fold
in five years.
You really have to be
honest with yourself
though in terms of whether
or not you have an edge.
There are four types--
information, analytic,
behavioral, and structural.
You also want to
ask yourself, what's
the consequence if I
am wrong, and can I
afford that consequence?
My advice is, if you
don't have an edge,
you start small, especially
with these growth
companies because we see how
core the subsequent investment
returns are.
And then build your
position over time
as you get to know
the company better.
You may get a better entry
point in terms of price
to intrinsic value.
And absolutely positively
have a sell strategy,
which is something we'll
cover here in a short moment.
For men especially,
you've got to guard
against overconfidence.
And there are people that have
gotten PhD's on this topic.
I'm not going to talk
about it at length.
You can look into
it if you want.
But Curt Schilling--
we live in Boston.
Curt Schilling of the
famous bloody sock,
retired, he was into games and
started a business, 38 Studios.
He put his entire $50 million
net worth into the business,
and then business went bankrupt.
Other examples of overconfidence
include the Hunt brothers
with silver in the 1970s
and then long-term capital
management.
I had my own
overconfidence story.
I invested in China
Media Express in 2011.
It seemingly passed the
three checklist items
that we've just
discussed-- high quality
earnings, competitive
advantage, and it was cheap.
It was selling at eight times
earnings, had $200 million
of cash, no debt, audited
financials by Deloitte.
Hank Greenberg,
who had built AIG
into one the preeminent
insurance companies,
he had put $80 million
into China Media Express.
And one of his colleagues
was on the board.
But, alas, China Media
Express was a fraud.
There was no $200 million.
So after the grieving
process was over,
I determined that I was going
to turn lemons into lemonade.
And I did a post-mortem
or in this case
an autopsy of what I
did wrong and identified
three errors, two of which
we're going to get to shortly.
And I realized that I never
wanted to be in a position
where I was down
25% on a portfolio.
So this leads to position size.
There is a study by Dr.
Van Tharp of people--
that they all get a
hypothetical $100,000.
They all get the same trades.
The same number
of winning stocks,
the same number
of losing stocks,
both in terms of
frequency and magnitude.
And yet, 50 simulated
trades later,
the ending balance of capital
ranges from completely
wipe out to $13 million.
And Dr. Thorpe says the reason
for this is position sizing
and in psychology.
So if you want to learn
more about position sizing,
I recommend this book.
This brings us to
step five, sell.
What's your exit strategy?
Before China Media Express, my
exit strategy was qualitative.
Position size gets
too big, maybe I
thought that the intrinsic value
of the company was declining,
maybe I thought I had a
better idea elsewhere.
Since China Media Express,
I realize that I've
got behavioral limits.
And so I wanted to introduce
some objective criteria
so I never turned small
loss into a big loss.
And so I'm going to go
through these items right now.
The first thing
I want to mention
is that selling is hard.
You've probably heard
this famous quotation
by Vince Lombardi.
Just put it into human
terms-- when you're a kid
and your mother was reading to
you when you were in your bed,
did your mom ever read to you
stories about great losers?
Or when you go into
the park, do you ever
see a statue of a great loser?
No.
We weren't wired
to be great losers.
And yet, as investors,
that costs us money.
So what I devised are
these safety switches.
And a safety switch
is simply-- it's
a button that if you see
the machinery breaking down,
you just hit that button
and the machinery turns off.
And this way you
stop the problem
before it gets even worse.
So I'm going to go over
four safety switches.
The first is a simple one.
Before you buy a
company, you determine,
what's the maximum
percentage decline
that you're willing to
let the stock go down?
Maybe it's 20%.
So if the stock then goes
down 21%, then you sell.
No ands ifs or buts.
I can't tell you what
the correct percentage
decline is, because
that's like me telling you
who you should date.
But, William O'Neil of
Investors Business Daily
who's an outstanding
investor-- he's
also written several books.
His rule of thumb is if a
position declines 7% to 8%
from its purchase
price, he sells.
If that's too rigorous, too
quick on the trigger for you,
maybe you something where
you sell 50% of your position
if it goes down 10%,
and the other 50% if it
the decline is 25%.
But you've got to have
this in writing before you
buy the stock because
once you own that stock,
you get all these
emotional bias kicking in.
There's a study
about coffee mugs.
A Nobel Prize was won by
Daniel Kahneman over the notion
that we'll pay $3
for a coffee mug
but we won't sell it unless
you offer us about $7.
That just doesn't make
any sense rationally.
But it gives you an idea
of some of these challenges
that we have at selling.
I want to point out
that sometimes you
may not be able to get a bid
if you're trying to sell.
You may say, all right, I'm
going to sell at 7% to 8%
or I'm going to sell
50% if I'm down 10%.
In this LinkedIn, in one
day last week it fell 35%.
You're not going to be
able to get in until you
get that 35% lower number.
So this is why position
sizing is important.
You've go to get that
position size correct,
even before you own the stock.
Now, Warren Buffett has
said his favorite holding
period is forever.
And that is true if you buy
and hold the right company.
If you buy and hold
a Microsoft or some
of these other companies.
But if you buy and
hold the wrong company,
then you could get wiped out.
I want to show you a chart
of a couple of companies.
Uranium Resources--
this company would've
turned a hypothetical
$10,000 into $17.
That's a 99.84% decline.
And Arch Coal, this would have
turned a hypothetical $10,000
into $2.81.
If you don't have
a safety switch,
you could ride one of
these things to zero.
And you get into this
point where I'm 25%,
you may even double down.
That is-- you can blow up
your portfolio quickly.
The second safety switch
is what I call the 1% rule.
So let's say you have a
hypothetical $100,000 portfolio
and you say, I willing to
lose a maximum of $1,000
on any position.
And so you can come up
with different scenarios
depending upon
how much you think
you might lose on
a percentage basis
before that stock then goes
up to its intrinsic value.
And the idea here is--
these are four scenarios.
A utility has historically
been a low volatility stock.
And then the highest
volatility stocks
would be companies
that are pre-revenue.
So you can use this approach to
think about what your position
sizing should be.
And the great thing
about this approach
is if you use the 1% rule, you
can have 10 successive losers
and you still have
90% of your capital.
So that's a discipline
repeatable and explainable
process that will protect you.
The third safety switch is
what I call reward to risk.
So let's say that
the stock's $50
and you think it's worth $65.
So your upside-- you're
expected profit is $15.
Now the smart money
says, have a reward
to risk ratio of at least three.
That's investing
probabilistically.
That means you're going
to bet $1 to make $3.
You don't want to
bet a $1 to make $2
or bet a $1 to make a $1.
That doesn't make sense.
So if then you buy the
stock and it goes up to $65,
you've made three
times your bet.
So congratulations.
Let's say you hang on and
it keeps going up to $75.
Now you've made
five times your bet.
That's even better.
However, let's say the
stock goes down to $45.
Well, you've bet
$5, you've lost $5.
So now you're minus one.
My recommendation is
this is where you sell.
If you're going to have a
stock that's losing money,
you never want to lose
more than your bet.
So this is the demarcation.
If however, you're too
stubborn and you're not
able to sell when the stock goes
down $10, now you're down two.
And then if you're hanging
on and it goes down to $25,
now you're at minus five.
So all I can say,
if you're going
to invest in a-- if
you have a stock that's
going down sell it a minus one.
Our fourth safety switch,
price-moving average-- now
this is an from Paul
Tudor Jones, billionaire
hedge fund manager and the
founder of the Robin Hood
Foundation which is created
to help children at risk.
And he has managed money
since the late 80s.
And I think his
record is-- I think
every year he's made money.
My metric for
everything I look at it
is the 200-day moving
average at closing prices.
I assume too many things go to
zero-- stocks and commodities.
This quotation is from Tony
Robbins' book [INAUDIBLE],
"Master the Game," which just
came out which is fantastic.
So we're going to start
looking at some companies using
this 200-day moving average.
Now, you don't even have to
use the earnings power chart
or some of the other methods.
You can just go to
StockCharts.com.
I think it's $15 dollars a
month for a subscription.
We'll start with
the bond market.
This is the corporate
bond market.
So if you're buying
a company's debt--
you can see that an
index of corporate debt,
the red-black line, that's
daily closing prices.
And that is $22.68.
This is a Vanguard index fund.
And then the average of the last
200 days of closing prices is
$22.50-- $22.60.
So on this basis,
Paul Tudor Jones--
I don't want to put
words in his mouth,
but my interpretation
is he would
be bullish on corporate bonds.
In contrast, we'll
look at stocks.
This is Vanguard's total
stock market index fund.
The 200-day moving
average is $50.60.
And then Friday's
close was $45.92.
So this means we're
in bear territory.
You never know how--
this is, you never
know how high a stock is
going to go or an index.
You never know how long
an index is going to go.
So this is an important
background information
because if you're thinking
of buying a company's stock,
75% of stocks are going to
go in the same direction
as the overall market.
So if you're thinking
about position sizing,
maybe you hold back that
position size in some way,
because we are in bear market
territory right now using
this approach.
Here's Microsoft's stock price
versus 200-day moving average
during the 1990s.
You can see that for
most of the time--
most of the time the blue
line, the moving average
was like a support level.
There were a couple of
times when the price went
below the 200-day
moving average,
but by and large
the closing price
was always above the
200-day moving average.
So by and large this
is a bullish trend.
In the 2000s you probably
know that Microsoft
ran into-- got disoriented.
We can see that there was
a 50% decline in 2000.
This is a 50% decline
after Microsoft
went under its 200-day
moving average.
So if this approach to
investing appeals to you,
you would have gotten out
before that 50% decline
if you apply these
methods rigorously.
And then in 2008 when we had
the global credit crisis.
Here again, Microsoft's
stock went down 50%
after the closing price went
below the 200-day moving
average.
So you had time to get out
if you were paying attention.
You're probably asking,
what about Alphabet?
Well, you're 6% above the
200-day moving average.
So this is a positive sign if
you're using this approach.
Interactive Brokers
is a stock that I own,
but I sold after
I noticed that it
went below its 200-day
moving average.
And you can see that
it then fell 24%.
Before China Media Express,
I would not have sold.
And then I would be in this
quandary, where, what do I do?
I never want to be in
that quandary again.
Deutsche Bank is down 45%.
It fell below its
200-day moving average.
And this an important
bank to watch
because as Deutsche Bank goes,
I think Europe will go too.
They've got $70
trillion of derivatives.
And if you own the bank, this
would have been a sell signal.
You're probably aware that
oil prices have gone down.
Oil is now 70% below its
200-day moving average.
So you if you had sold in
August of 2014 at about $100,
congratulations.
The last price is about $31.
So you don't know how low
these prices are going to go.
But you just know that either
you reduce your position size
or you introduce a hedge element
or take other action that
protects your wealth.
Horsehead Holding is down
99.48% in less than one year.
Look how violently some of
these companies can collapse.
Linn Energy, down 99% since it
went below its 200-day moving
average.
Now, probably some of
you are math majors.
So check this out.
After Linn went below its
200-day moving average
it fell 50% to $14.
And you may think, it
fell 50%, now it's cheap.
Well then it fell
another 50% to $7.
Now it's really cheap.
And then it fell to $3.50.
And now you're thinking,
where's the truck?
I'm going to back up the truck.
And then it fell
another 50% to $1.75.
another 70% to $0.37.
The more you lose, the
harder it is to recover.
If you're down 10%, you only
need 11% to get back up.
If you're down
25%, you need 33%.
You're down 50%,
now you need 100%.
So that's a one bagger.
Now check out how asymmetric
the math gets here.
If you're down 75% you
need a 300% return.
That's a three-bagger.
Down 90%, you need
a 900% return.
Down 99%, 9,900%.
Now in my case, I was down 100%.
So I get this number
sign division number.
And that just means,
you know, really bad.
So the key point I want to give
you is, if the ship is sinking
you got to get off.
And if you have trouble
selling, there's
this great book
that just came out
called, "The Art of Execution,"
by Lee Freeman-Shor.
It came out last fall.
I read it in one night.
It's terrific.
There are five personality
approaches he identifies.
Read the book and see
what personality type
you are and maybe you can
improve your decision-making.
All right.
Here at the Googleplex you
have at least 30 cafes,
including Cafe BADALL.
So this is the sign that
we're about to wrap things up.
So, what I suggest is that you
do a self-assessment of what
investment grade you are.
If you focus on the stock
price, then you are a beginner.
If you focus on an earnings
quality, which I hope you do.
If you used the
earnings power chart,
then you're an
intermediate investor.
If you're focusing
on valuation-- price
to intrinsic value, value
drivers, competitive advantage,
then you're an
advanced investor.
And if you're focusing things
only position size and reward
to risk, exit strategies, then
you're an expert investor.
So there are two actions
that I recommend.
You can do these today,
do these tonight.
The first is, define
your strategy.
It should have three part.
What kind of companies
are you looking to buy?
What things are you
going to think about
while you own that business?
In other words, how are
you going to keep up
to date with the moves.
And then, what are the exit
strategies for you to sell?
Put this in writing,
because if you
don't put it in
writing then you really
don't have an exit strategy.
You don't have an
investment strategy.
The second thing
I mentioned to do
is create an investment journal.
So if open up
Google Docs, Excel,
and every time
you buy a stock, I
want you to put in the
company's name, the symbol,
the number of shares you
buy and the purchase price.
I want you put in your estimate
of the intrinsic value.
And then I want you put in-- you
can have a formula that tells
you the reward to risk ratio.
It should be at
least, what, three.
OK.
Paul Tudor Jones, do you
know what he looks for?
Five.
So if you want be a
billionaire, look for fives.
And then when it comes to
time to sell your position,
make a couple of
other data entries--
the sell price, the date,
what your thesis is.
Maybe the company broke
the 200-day moving average.
Maybe the thesis is not as
attractive as-- whatever
the reason is, just make a
note of that information.
Then you can compare your
actual reward to risk ratio
to your expected reward ratio.
And if you notice that there are
too many negative-- you know,
minus 1.5, minus 1.2,
minus-- excuse me, minus one,
minus two, minus
threes, then you
need to rethink your approach.
If I had to sum up
everything, the one thing
that I want you to remember--
you [INAUDIBLE] forget
everything else that I said
is, do not turn a small loss
into a big loss.
And with that, I want
to thank you very much.
It's been exciting to come
here and think about what
I was going to say to you.
My father-in-law, Carl
Peterson is an engineer.
He was a professor at MIT
of mechanical engineering.
Probably most of you are
electrical engineers.
This is my first presentation
to a non-finance group.
So if you have any questions I'm
happy to take them, and if not,
thanks again.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so, I had
two questions actually.
This is all very interesting.
So the one question is if both
valuing approaches are so good,
why don't you combine them?
Have you tried looking
at them together?
Subtracting all of
them-- that would
lower even-- that would
increase the gap to gap.
But maybe that's a good thing.
And then a second question is--
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Let
me take that first.
And let me throw the
question back at you.
Why didn't you think we want
one alternate income statement?
And let's start
with investment--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HEWITT HEISERMAN:
Well let's start
with investment
in fixed capital.
And I always think
about this like you've
got a commercial banker
and a venture capitalist
sitting across the
desk from each other.
And they're arguing
each of these four
structural limitations the
GAAP income statement has.
The commercial banker's
going to say, look,
there are studies that say
that more capital intensive
the business, the more likely
it is that that company is going
to go bankrupt.
Now I excluded them
from this presentation
in the interests of time, but
the studies are out there.
So the reason that the
defensive investor wants to look
at capital spending is
because-- especially if you know
the business, he
may want to say, OK,
why is Alphabet's-- what are
they spending their money on?
Is it to maintain-- you
get 100% of your profits
from search, right.
From what I read, almost 100%.
So I want to know, if I'm
an analyst, how much of that
capex is going to search.
And then how much is
it going to your bets.
I know that you know search.
But I may not have the
same degree of confidence
that you know medicine
or space or some
of these other initiatives
that you're working on.
So I may want to take a more
conservative approach when
I'm tracking your uses of cash.
Now the venture capitalist,
he's going to say,
they've got a
great track record.
I've worked with
them for 10 years.
The owners own a large
slug of the business.
I have total confidence in
how those investments are
going to work out.
When you're working
with companies
that are not of your caliber,
this is a very important item
to look at.
If you're dealing a retailer
for example, and they
make sweaters.
And you notice
that their inventor
is piling up at Christmas.
Well you know they're going
to have a bad quarter,
because if they can't
sell at Christmas,
they're not going to be
selling the first quart.
Christmas is the selling season.
So it's a way of diving into a
company's financial statements
with maybe a more informed
view of the business.
I'll give you one more--
stockholder's equity.
A company is not obligated to
pay the stockholders any fixed
rate of return.
When you buy a company's stock,
you don't sign a contract
with the business.
However, when that company
borrows money from a bank,
there is a contract saying
that the borrower is
going to pay live worth
plus 100 basis points.
And the lender is going to
put a lien on the assets.
That doesn't happen in
the enterprising mindset.
So there are two
different mindsets here.
And what I want to do is I
want to almost like hear it
in stereo.
You know, that's just
better music than mono.
You had another question?
OK.
We'll come back.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about that the last part
on selling.
In one of the older
letters, Buffett
had give an example of
the Washington Post of how
the Washington Post
was worth $400 million
and if it went down
50%, he would basically
just buy more rather
than sell the stock
because the intrinsic value of
the business has not changed.
So obviously the
difference is in his case,
he has an analytical edge, and
he understands the business
and he knows that the
Washington Post is truly
worth $400 million
and he would not sell.
In our case, I'm assuming,
what you're saying is,
we have these kind
of objective rules,
because maybe our analytical
edge or understanding
of the business is not as
strong as buffers Buffet's.
So my question is, why even
bother with picking stocks
if our analytical edge is
not enough to protect us
from the volatility?
Why not just do
indexing and not bother?
Is there any
reason-- so, to me it
seems like it's
mutually exclusive.
Either I understand the business
and I should be stock picking,
or I don't understand
the business
and I should just be indexing.
Why do this half kind of a
thing where I don't quite
understand the business?
I have these rules and
yet be stock picking.
HEWITT HEISERMAN:
Well to your point
about Mr. Buffett,
the Washington
Post-- I think he said he
believed that the business was
worth about $400.
And he was buying when
it was $80 million.
Right.
Now remember, he had an edge
because he owned Buffalo News.
So he knew the business.
Plus I believe he
got a board seat.
So not only did he have
information advantage
and behavioral damage
and analytic advantage,
but he could help influence
management's capital
allocation.
Most of us don't have
that opportunity.
So to the question
about index funds,
that's what Mr.
[INAUDIBLE] would say.
He would say that you should
use low-cost index funds.
But as he told me in a
conversation we had once,
he said, most of us
have a little bit
of a gambling instinct.
If there's a company
that we like,
if we use their search function
25 times a day for 15 years,
we might think that
that business is
going to be around
for a while, and we
want to participate
in the its success.
But by the same
token, I'm not going
to pretend that I know
the business intimately.
So you want to just have
some protection in case
you misjudged the business.
Now, those numbers that I gave
you, the 1% rule for example.
That may not work for you.
Maybe you want to use
2% or 3%, whatever
it is, that's
something that you've
got to figure out for yourself.
You may only want to buy
a couple of companies.
Most companies do not make
it the upper right box
in the earnings power chart.
Very few forge that
earnings power staircase.
AUDIENCE: And just a
clarifying question if you may.
I guess my point
is, if we are not
in the same position
as Buffett where
we do have an analytical edge,
why even bother is my point?
We are getting the benefit of
owning Alphabet by-- Alphabet
is part of the index.
And if it's going
to do well it's
going to be a bigger
part of the index.
So why bother anyway?
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Well,
I find this business
to be the most interesting
business there is.
There's something new every day.
You're thinking about, not only
things in a quantitative sense,
in terms of earning quality,
but qualitative too--
competitive advantage,
landscape analysis, [INAUDIBLE]
five forces.
To me it's a
intellectual challenge.
And so I enjoy the process.
If someone doesn't
enjoy this type of work,
they should have their money
professionally managed.
So if you have a business
that you drive by every day
or that you deal with-- there's
a newspaper that you, whatever.
You have some sort of
intimate personal relationship
with a business and you think
you want to be an owner,
I'm trying to give
you a strategy
to help tilt the odds of
success in your favor.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is-- it's
going to look like it's
along the same lines
but it's with a different focus.
Buffett, when he was asked about
Berkshire and the price moving
up and down, I think in 2012
or '13 he said, you know,
there are times when the price
to book varies from 1.2 to 4.
And he says-- I quote
him here, "unless you
can watch your stock
holdings decline by 50%
without becoming
panic-stricken, you
should not be in
the stock market."
So it looks like it's
the same, but my question
is actually different.
Given the volatility
of stocks, if there's
anything like a 10% or 1% or
20% rule, does it make sense?
Are you giving up the
opportunity of being fearful
and others greedy and being
greedy when others are fearful?
HEWITT HEISERMAN: Let's
go back to the 1%.
Here are four scenarios.
If you expect-- let's focus
on the micro-cap company.
In this scenario you're thinking
I can handle 35% decline.
But then I think that it's
going to go up ten-fold
because all your friends are
drinking the product, using
the product.
It's got its secular tailwind.
So you just figure out,
what's the most volatility
that I can live with.
And then if you can think
about it in those terms,
then you can figure out
your position sizing.
So yeah, then the position
goes down 30%, no big deal
because you still are
following your strategy.
Where if you want to
handle a 75% decline,
which sometimes
happens, then you've
got your position sizing
here so that you're covered.
The point is that you
need a strategy in place
before you buy the stock.
Now, you mentioned
Berkshire Hathaway.
And Berkshire lost 50%
of its market value
four times since it went public.
So even the bluest
of blue chips can
suffer those kinds of decline.
And the other thing
I want to point out
is, let's see you
misunderestimate
how far a company falls.
And you follow your strategy
and you sell your position.
You don't have to-- that
doesn't mean that you
can't buy that position back.
What you could do is you say,
OK, I'll buy it back in--
say I'll buy back
25% of my position
after the next 10Q or
the next 10K is filed.
And if there's a
smoking gun, if it's
a company-specific
reason-- fraud,
something else, some reason
that you don't know about,
but maybe leads
to your investors
do and that's why the
price is declining,
well you wait until the
next SEC filing comes out
and then you buy back your
position, starting say 25%
a quarter for four
quarters, then
you're back to your
original position.
So you can have these
work-arounds and these apps
to help you get back
into a position.
If you think you're
selling Microsoft in 1991
or Berkshire Hathaway in 1975.
MALE SPEAKER: We have time
for one final question.
AUDIENCE: My question
is in a similar line,
I want a clarification--
you say you
want to sell when it drops
below a certain percentage.
Nowadays the market even
fluctuates so much, right,
based on given
news and something.
A lot of people,
even pundits have
said that certain good stocks,
if you have it-- example,
Microsoft or [INAUDIBLE]
or something,
they could fluctuate
10% in a given week,
and you could be missing
out on 10 baggers
100 baggers if you act on
this volatility, right.
So when you say you sell on
a certain percentage down,
are you discounting
the volatility?
Or if your fund-- or if your
stock is 10% below the market,
we just-- let's say, the
S&P today has opened up 5%
and my stock went 10%.
So I'm only down 5% or am I
really down 10% [INAUDIBLE]?
HEWITT HEISERMAN:
That's a great question.
I didn't address it.
That's something
for you to answer.
Do you want to
sell your positions
if they're falling at
the same rate of decline
as the overall market?
Or are you looking for say
some decline that's above
and beyond what the
market decline is?
And I don't know the
answer to that for you
because these are personal
decisions that have to make.
What I'm trying to
say is, in my case,
I recognize one
of my limitations
is that getting emotional about
a position that's down 25%,
and I don't want to be
in that position again.
And so I created
some strategies so
that that's not going to occur.
So you may decide that
you'll put up with the market
volatility, you're
just going to focus
on the company-specific
volatility.
And that may be an
excellent approach.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for an engaging talk
and provocative conversations.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]